[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen Bal
uh this has been a uh a hectic week you
know I don't know when this is going to
air here but we do know it oh yeah this
is going to air we do know when this
yeah and this is actually airing right
after I I have done my live
podcast so I can't wait to be talking
about that but I'm going to live in the
moment MH and I'm going to uh
enjoy just being there with people and
just laughing and and talking to Zach
and uh I mean people say are you really
nervous about it I was so nervous when I
did mine I mean sure they're nerves but
it's more nerves about making sure
everything is right the sound the you
know things that I can't control are the
things you usually worry about I know I
can control you know talking to the
audience having some laughs some
questions to Zach
improvising but you can't control
everything and you have to just sort of
delegate is that the right word yeah
delegate those sort of uh things to the
people who know what they're doing and
and hope that it goes smoothly I hope
you know I what's the worst Cas scenario
people worst case scenario is like they
go yeah it was really lame and then they
move on to the next thing I hope that's
not the case I go yeah you know that was
pretty fun it was cool yeah podcast
people will not hold as harsh grudges as
you think really that that I think
that's a life lesson yeah I think you're
right on on the yeah more yeah more
often than not yeah okay well anyway uh
I hope all is well with you guys we have
a great podcast today uh Candace King is
here and she's a freaking Delight
um you know we went out a few times
years ago we talk about that which I
didn't think we would um but she's so
open and she has a podcast and uh I did
it it's amazing we'll talk all about
that stuff and uh we talk about Vampire
Diaries and we talk a little bit about
everything uh real quick before you
listen if you like the show if you say
hey you know what this guy doesn't suck
I'd like to listen more interviews we
have so many interviews that you could
uh go down the rabbit hole with the uh
handles give them the handles they could
follow us oh God at inside of you pod on
Twitter at insb podcast on Instagram and
Facebook that's correct you can watch on
YouTube and uh write a review which
really helps And subscribe subscribe it
means a lot You' also go to the inside
of you online store and get tons of
merch Smallville stuff signed by me
Lexus scripts and ship keys and on the
tovil podcast.com if you're a Smallville
fan we have um this artist made pictures
of me and Tom from the show and we only
did 55 prints and so those are on sale
get them because there's only 55 and
then they're gone so uh um those are on
the tville podcast and uh yeah I'm on
the Cameo and a lot of other stuff also
go to my uh Instagram handle at the
Michel rosenbom um in the bio is the
link tree and that has all the cons that
Tom and I will be at and um we're doing
Smallville nights and a bunch of other
stuff so make sure you hit that and find
out where we are and come hug us I like
to see the patrons I like to see you so
there you go patreon.com inside you if
you want to join and support the podcast
which I couldn't do this podcast without
you couldn't do this podcast with that
Ryan Ryan's here I'm here um yeah
exciting stuff are you uh you're doing
all right I'm doing okay yeah why why
okay I'm doing okay I'm doing okay
man just uh stress uh stressed out
stressed out by by things in life and
trying to cope with it and trying not to
peel peel my skin off and ride in a hole
well what can you do that's what we have
to just say is like what can I do about
the stress that I'm feeling if if it's
if you can't do anything about it right
now then you got to shove it you you
were talking about that today shelving
things shelving thing if you can't
control it and you can't change it shove
it it it serves no purpose you're
thinking about something that you can't
change so you're just like right now I
could sit here and go oh my gosh the P
the live podcast you know what if
there's no uh t-shirt gun but it did go
well because we're in the future we're
in the future so it did go well it did
did go well Ryan that's for sure thanks
um anyway enjoy the podcast uh let me
know what you think I really appreciate
you guys and um let's get inside of
Candace King it's my point of VI you're
to inside of you with Michael Rosen
[Music]
B inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of live studio
audience how are you you look the same
as when I met you I don't know 15 years
ago or God I yeah it would have been
that um yeah it would have been around
15 years ago um thank you I I guess um
yeah how do you look so good is that Ean
skin products Evan what is that um I'm
obsessed with skin care I really am um I
I actually I'm not trying to sound like
an [__] but I I've only gotten Botox
like two times maybe three times in my
entire life what two of the times it's
gone completely wrong like I'm jinxed
like God test me for my vanity and I
just don't need a tester anymore so I uh
I really just stick to the skin creams
and and filters you know you gotta love
a filter I I love fil are you using a
filter right
now probably and but I wouldn't even
know how to take it off I don't know if
there is one actually we got a Ryan I
did set up a nice light I am in my in my
um new living room to be you know
officially a living room eventually so I
strategically picked the colors on the
wall this is all this is all on purpose
I like it I like it who's watching the
kids right now they're at school I know
I have a seven-year-old and a two and a
halfy old and uh so my two and a halfy
old is actually in preschool now so I'm
like actually I know but I they're at
school right now I'm trying to relieve
some of my mommy guilt but I feel like
it's it's for them but I'm going to see
them later tonight cuz right when I get
off the this call with you I'm going to
head over it's a very big week it's been
a big two weeks here in Nashville
there's been special sessions having to
do with you know gun safety laws and uh
just common sense gun laws here so you
know I'm going to go meet some galp Pals
over at the capital and just see what's
up really just going after it going
after it going after why not they call
the people's house because you can just
go there and watch what's happening it's
pretty cool I love Bravo television but
now I'm like hey this is very
entertaining like anyone who's in a
Bravo should just go to the capital
building and see what's going on you
will be just as entertained I promise
you I like this I like this you know I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna say it I read
something it says women that Michael
rosenbom has dated and I don't know why
because I'm very secretive and whatever
but you and I went on one date 15 years
ago and I think it was more than one
date for first of all well I'd like to
say that but like you're the one who
didn't call me back so I was like you
know even when I was like hey I'd love
to interview you I was like no I'm not
but yeah I was like you know I yeah I I
I thought it was a great date but you
know obviously it didn't uh you know it
takes two to tango but uh you know it
says that I'm like well we only okay we
went on a few dates but we went to an
event and I think people saw us at an
event and so they assume we were dating
like you know oh they're serious if
they're at an event together but we were
both kind of C WWB you know a network
without three letters and uh so I think
that's kind of you know what happen and
that's why it always says Candice how do
you say your last name your your old
last name well my my maiden last name uh
is akola and my I even though I'm
divorced I'm keeping my um married last
name is King it's Candace King yeah it
sounds better than Candace AKA or
Candace King I know I know my dad my dad
I'm like I'm sorry Dad it wasn't even
you know my um my ex and I went the
discussion of like you get asked like
are you keeping your name or not and I
just like dude it's an upgrade like it's
a great last name and we had a nice
chuckle uh so it's a good it's a good
solid name and and I and yes Mike
children bear the same name and so I
should be using it for that instead of
vanity but you know um but Candace King
just has a nice ring to it but I'm
curious what what article what article
said that where did you was it written
by
michaelo no I mean if you look up
Michael Rosen mom dating P it's got
people on there that I don't even
know like there's women on there that
I've never met what am I sefel now what
is what what's going
on AA King Frozen bomb no I don't know
but it was like and I and I I saw your
and I was like I wish I had dated
her we went I think we went on like
three dates
okay cuz I remember cuz you you I
remember in particular that you were a
very good date planner and you've
actually in like my list of like top
dates like date experiences yours is on
there what yes and I'd be very
embarrassed if you're like I didn't take
you no I remember I remember I liked you
I like you're adorable but like there
was there was uh there was we went p p
golfing I think one for one of them I
think that was my last time doing it and
then my other but the one that like
really sticks out is it was my first
time ever experiencing the Hollywood
Bowl and you took me to go see Carol
King and James Taylor and I got you a
shirt and you what I got you a shirt you
got me a shirt yep you don't remember
that I remember that I remember that see
I mean Carol King I know and and it was
such a great concert to the point where
like James Taylor cried when he's sang
Fire and Rain Carol King was like
jumping up with the backup singer
singing with them while James Taylor was
I mean it was just it could not been
like a better like it was awesome it was
like one of the top one of the best
dates you could ever recall in your life
and then that was it now my my thought
was and Ryan here who you can't see my
engineer is probably thinking he said
something like well maybe she met this
rock star right after right during and
then she was like oh Rockstar Rosen bomb
I'm gonna go rockstar no no it wasn't
right all right it just didn't feel
right whatever the reason was but I I
wanted to bring it up to is this why you
wanted to bring me on here just to like
get closer have you been holding on to
this is there like a voodoo doll of me
in in your basement there is there's no
I I have nothing bad to say about you I
was like she's a sweet talented awesome
lady Lady Lady sounds a girl yeah just a
girl I was a young lady no I look I
think um we don't need to talk about I
just wanted to hey you want to talk
about it let's talk about it no I you're
an open book I like that I am an open
book um no I I feel like looking back
because I knew we were going to probably
talk about this and I thought about it
and I knew that we were just in
different places like yeah you had been
in the business for a while you had had
like great success and and like and at a
time when success came with like
attention and premieres and parties and
like you know an events that is very
different than it is now you know now
like success is like it's people on
social media it was different then and
you had already experienced this ride
like on a network that obviously you
know you know because you were on it as
well it's a very like specific
experience because it's also like a
young audience and and so and I was at
the very beginning of M I know I know I
know you were just getting going I was
just getting going and I could tell like
things that I was excited about you were
maybe already like like been there done
that maybe like we're over you know what
I mean you were saying that I wasn't
sharing your excitement is what you're
saying that's what you're saying this is
you see this Ryan it was thrown back on
me I am always delighted and excited for
people's success but no look I get it
100% I mean we're in different places I
was in Vancouver I was going back and
forth I think it was just for whatever
it was a moment in time it was nice we
had a great time something we remember
uh the James Taylor concert you won't it
was yeah and the pup putt was fantastic
yeah I won I'm sure of that probably
probably I don't hold back like if I
ever do things like that when I'm on a
if I'm on a date and I have and I
haven't gone on tons of dates I mean I
guess I have't my life well I can check
the list I mean when I research you now
I got to check your list of all well
just know that some of them aren't real
some of I think we're going to just go
through every single person and be like
yes no y'll just give you signs like a
green sign and a red sign well you know
what's funny is because now that I know
you're an open book and you've got you
know the podcast Super Bloom and you
talk about people's lives and their um
you because we do that too we talk about
mental health and we talk about life and
Journeys and I was like I shouldn't
bring up the divorce thing right and of
for first thing you bring up is the
divorce so but like you seem so together
I guess it was amicable right I mean
look I think that it is that that is for
anyone who's ever experienced it um and
what I'll say is just on the receiving
end like when I
realized like when I found myself in the
position of uh understanding what the
divorce the word divorce really meant
and not just emotionally but also like
the business of it you know it's just
like it there's a reason why it's on a
list of like some of the most stressful
things that also includes like moving
job loss death and you even you know as
an adult or reading stories or having
people who have experienced great loss
in their life when they talk about
someone that they lose or you know the
death of like friends of mine that have
lost a parent they'll also then get into
like it's the business of dying that is
just
so taxing emotionally which is like
canceling out all the credit cards you
know do like all these like day-to-day
the house the house and the it's all the
things and so what was interesting is to
to find myself on the receiving end of a
of a community of friends who had been
through that experience and were who a
were able to you know hold my hand
through a lot of that and I think that
that's probably like it's just it's no
matter what it's a it's a it's difficult
and we also like share children together
not just children from our own marriage
but I was very involved with my uh you
know in watching my stepchildren grow up
and so it's like you know like of there
I I don't I feel like there is no one
word that encapsulates what what divorce
is it's um there's many
words it's a
process I look I don't I don't think
that there's one word that really
encapsulates the entire
process this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem to do it oh yeah yeah therapy
helps you figure out what's holding you
back so your brain can work for you
instead of against you and this is what
happens with um therapy you're you have
all these things bottled up and you need
to let them out and you need to talk to
a professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapists anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like I
want to try someone else it's easy just
like that better help is truly the best
way to make your brain your friend give
it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com inside inside of you is brought
to you by discover if you like using
debit over credit don't you think it's
time you also get rewarded well now you
can with discover cashback debit it's a
checking account that rewards everyone
with cash back on everyday purchases
plus there are no fees period we're
talking date nights thrifting the latest
trends nights out with your friends and
it's now earning you cash back with
discover cashback debit check out
eligibility and terms at discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member
FDIC yeah well I will say this I think
that there's a pressure too that I mean
the way I look at it maybe because I've
just maybe I'm a little more cynical or
maybe I I look at things like hey most
the time when you go out with someone
whether it's a great date to James
Taylor or whatever you don't it ends 99%
of those dates they're not the one and
so when you finally found the
one 50% of the time that doesn't work
out so you know the chances if you look
at odds and you shouldn't when you're in
love and you go hey this is this is it
I'm living in the moment I'm just I'm
following my heart but the pressure of
I'm in Hollywood I don't want to be one
of those Hollywood actresses that get
divorced and you know I want this to be
forever I always think if I if I'm going
to do it I want it to be my forever and
I don't want to be like a statistic but
it's like you have to know in the back
of your head like
hey you know this is a long time you're
saying I do to someone for could be the
next 50 60 years of your life
and one of the chances that's going to
work out I know that sounds kind of
effed but you know did you put pressure
on yourself at all going you know I
don't want to be that or did you not
think about that stuff is this how you
talk to girls on dates
now statistically no I know no but I do
but I do talk to my girlfriends who are
like they put so much weight on things
and we all do it's not just women men as
well but like Hey try to enjoy the
moment try to enjoy the person and see
what happens but but just know that most
things don't work out the way you plan
so don't
don't project don't look into the future
take everything one day at a time and I
know that's difficult but anyway yeah no
it's definitely difficult I think that
there's also you know look this is
complet this this part is completely
separate from me but just you bringing
up friends and like and just the general
experience I think that there's also two
biological elements to this you know
there's also like don't put pressure
don't think in the future but anyone but
if you are someone who is born with a
uterus and who wants to carry or have a
child or you know there is there is it's
impossible and this is for someone that
wants children I know that there are
plenty of uterus owning people in the
world who maybe not do not want children
you say uterus owning yeah U if you have
a if you have a uterus and you want to
have a baby right um and I think that
there are some but if you do want to
have a child um there is something to
think about in the future like if if you
have the ability and that's something
that you want then there is there is
like obviously looking into the future
and again that's completely separate
from my circumstance but I just like I
understand why you know you might have
conversations with friends of yours who
are women that are thinking like that
right but um but yeah no think that like
there's also so many different things
that come down to it I think it it
changes like if you do think of it and
consider it in like a present-minded
mode you know you start thinking about
like if you and if you do have children
like it affects other people as well um
and then there's also just the reality
of relationships you know the es and
flows of any relationship be it like
business familial and romantic that uh
there there is not a period of time
where you're just getting along all the
time you have to work on it and so I
think that that comes into play too in
um any sort of long-term relationship is
just you know you work on it and and you
see what happens but um yeah it's s it's
such a personal thing and it's so
specific to like um there is no like one
siiz fits-all at all like there is
things that work for friends of mine
even in just like friendships and in in
relationships where how I interact with
some friends is going to be different to
how I emotionally interact with other
friends because those relationships call
for you know different things yeah um
that's my roundabout answer I I I love
it I think it's very mature and it makes
me look at things differently yes uh
being a uterus owning individual
I I understand what you're saying and I
maybe I don't understand what you're
saying because why should I I don't I'm
not uterus
owning so but um uter you know what I'm
saying someone has a u there're also
women in the world who have H who have
their uteruses removed at different you
know it's like there's so many we could
go into that conversation 10 million
different ways I'm just saying if you
are someone and you have like and you
decide that you physically are able to
carry a child because you and that you
want to do that like you're going to
project and think in the future of a
timeline and um and of course then and
then that gets into a whole route where
if you don't have those organs there's a
million ways that people can make
families and create babies and so yeah
but that's what I mean when I say that
it's very articulate you are you you
said it great you said it well not great
I wasn't very good in English um you
know I see your Instagram and it just
looks like you have so much fun like
you're at the Taylor Swift concert you
know you're wearing your little outfits
and you're with your friends and you're
taking pictures and you're just enjoying
life are you do you feel like that
you're trying to do that even more now
um to just sort of I mean has have
things changed you went through this
lull probably with the divorce and all
these things you had to do but are you
trying to just go hey I need to get out
there I need to have fun I need to enjoy
life is that kind of the mentality oh my
no I'm so I feel very grateful I've
always been having that much fun like it
and also I have tons of days where I'm
not having fun you know and I'm very
stressed and anxious and and I came home
last night from just like a wonderful
trip and I'm I'm missing my babies and
and I can slather on the mom guilt and
just wear it like a heavy backpack and
look around a house I just moved into
that you know I finally just got rid of
a smell one place but then this is
broken and then that's broken and
there's a like I can you know but I can
look at the world that way and only look
at the things that can be very
frustrating I also think that I can also
see really wonderful beautiful things so
and and there's also something to be
said that Instagram and social media is
just the Highlight Reel we know that
this is just a highlight reel I'm not
someone who airs my Grievances and
that's and that's just me and I
understand that for some people that
that works for them and I think that
that's wonderful you know why um because
I think that I think you're right nobody
wants to see Debbie Downer everything
sucks life sucks because we all life can
suck for for everyone and so maybe
that's why we get on the Instagram
however that being said like we want to
see all the good things but that's why I
think you know not to toot my own horn
but like listening to podcasts where
people have real conversations or your
podcast or other many podcasts out there
but um I think there's a place for for
Instagram um I think it you know
obviously it's blown out of proportion
and everybody thinks that everyone lives
the best life and there's this jealousy
thing and I wish I had their life and I
I I used to think that way and I have
friends who are huge successful people
way more successful than I am but I
don't want their lives at all because
everyone has their [__] everyone has
their [__] and but I don't think you
want to air that
[__] on a platform where everybody could
see it it's okay to say hey I've been
through this blah blah I can relate that
but like you know but in Instagram is
that place where you go and you're like
oh my gosh that's funny that's funny
that's hilarious and you just you know
and you just keep clicking for the next
great thing but every once in a while
all those happy things then you hit
something like something really sad and
you're like oh my God that's tragic and
then you just go oh another thing and
that's funny and you just it's just just
back I don't know what I'm talking about
but anyway but I I think it's
generational too I think like that our
generation wants to see the happy things
you know we were part of the
kind of the the birth of this social
media app where people just you know
first it was Twitter and just updating
like happy quirky funny thoughts and you
know that's funny that that's where it
started and then now it and then
Instagram started with just
photos and um and it's you know turned
into other things I think for like a
younger generation might see it as an
opportunity to feel less alone but then
just parallel to that they could also
see it as an opportunity to feel more
lonely because they don't see themselves
in the videos that are being curated to
them and it's making them feel bad so it
is like you have to pick and choose you
have to it's kind of like like a radio
station like you have to go through the
radio like or or for the children
listening if there are any it's kind of
like your Spotify playlist you got to
like go in and curate your own playlist
that's going to make you feel really
good um because I mean it gets it can
get to the best of us too I mean I've
definitely gone on social media and and
had that feeling of like oh wow look
look what's happening I've had that fomo
of uh you know and and fallen into the
comparison pitfalls of that's the worst
comparing is the worst it is and and
that is also I think something that's
really like not to say that there isn't
anyone who in various other Industries
but I would imagine it's pretty
heightened in the film in television uh
anyone who's an actor is definitely felt
that way and it's really hard hard to
stay in your own lane you know and like
it's like for it's stuck with me but I
always think of it um some like I don't
know where I read or saw this but the
idea of like you know if you're a
swimmer and you're swimming in your lane
if you constantly are just looking over
what everyone else is doing and what
their time is you're just slowing
yourself down hang on though see in my
mind I'm like oh [__] I got to pick it
up that guy's beating me I got to get to
that Finish Line before that dude that's
funny no it slows me down it shuts down
my creativity I go
already doing that so I might as well
just it's like Chris Hemsworth he's
doing more squats on Instagram what am I
doing oh my God I gotta I gotta start
doing I'm like no you don't you don't
need to look you first of all
genetically you're just not Crim
crimsworth crims Crimson hensworth
you're just not that guy hensworth by
the way are you uh are you friends with
Taylor Swift no why oh but you're
friends with Miley Cyrus no why no I
worked worked for her um I was a backup
singer on one of her tours I know I find
that fting she's worked with yeah but um
we know a lot of the same people um but
I haven't run into her in years but oh
my gosh she has this beautiful new
song Jess is telling me about this new
song and I go ah oh my gosh I don't know
if Miley S I listen to Chicago and like
you know the Cure and stuff like that
and well James tell but you know I don't
I don't really listen to Miley s but
when I've listened to her she's got a
great voice and stuff should I listen to
the song
yes no you should and you should watch
her her video of it it's very beautiful
it basically just is like which I've had
this conversation on repeat with so many
of my uh friends in my 30s especially
like female friends who are looking back
on like our late teens and our early 20s
with such Grace who for these like young
versions of ourselves that we may have
judged really hard for a long time like
it it took me a long time to just not
feel embarrassed or ashamed at um so
many parts of of who I was when I was in
my like late teenage years especially
and my early 20s I know and just really
kind
of and it's it's been really freeing to
now all of a sudden look back at this
like young girl and just tell her like
you you were doing great like you know
don't listen to everyone else and you're
like you're just you're figuring it out
out and it's okay to figure it out and
it's okay to make mistakes and it's okay
to be loud and it's okay to be quiet and
it's okay to ask questions um and so I
feel like listening to her song it was
just this beautiful you know musical
kind of part of that conversation that
I've had with so many women lately and
and also she's just always had an
amazing voice even when she was 14 and I
was lucky enough to uh be backing her up
although I noticed like did you notice
all those Instagram
when she's talking and she's like well I
was like doing and then they cut into a
frog doing it like
going I haven't seen you haven't seen
those it's pretty funny I mean she
doesn't talk like that but everybody
wants to make fun of everybody it's I
people make fun of me all the time it's
just the way it
is inside of you is brought to you by
neurohacker I've talked about this many
time so if you're listening I think you
should listen again unless you've
ordered some of this stuff it's it's
really really helped me with focus and
energy and it's science so uh hear me
out on this if if someone would have
told me that there are science-backed
ingredients that could help me feel 15
years younger in a matter of months I
wouldn't believe it and then I tried
Quia senolytic this is something guys
that I was taking before they were a
sponsor and I didn't even know they were
a sponsor and I said I'm feeling good
and I'm not stopping taking this if
that's the right English I wasn't going
to stop and then they're like oh oh yeah
you got spots and I go oh they sent it
to me I thought I had ordered this I've
talked about this before but boy has
this really changed the way I'm feeling
and uh the way I'm thinking it has uh
changed me in for the better there's no
doubt about it as we age everyone
accumulates senent cells in their body
senent cells may cause symptoms of Aging
such as aches and pains slow workout
recoveries sluggish mental and physical
energy associated with that middle-aged
in h i I know that uh also known as
zombie cells they are old and worn out
and not serving a useful function for
our health anymore but they could be
taking up space and nutrients from our
healthy cells much like pruning the
yellowing and Dead Leaves off a plant
Quia cenotic helps remove those worn out
Cent cells to allow for the rest of them
to thrive in the body it makes perfect
sense and that's what's happening to me
I'm taking them
Ryan and good yeah and all you have to
do is take them two days a month wow
that's pretty incredible the formula is
non-GMO vegan gluten-free and the
ingredients are meant to complement one
another factoring in the combined effect
of all ingredients together and Ryan it
has a 100 day money back guarantee
anytime a product has that I'll try it
I'll try it if I'm going to get my money
back that's how uh confident they are um
look higher levels of energy uh feeling
a lot younger these are good things I'm
more productive uh more enthusiastic
about my life less aches and pains which
you know if you listen to the podcast
that I
have um look help resist aging at the
cellular level try qualia senolytic go
to neurohacker
docomo
15% off say goodbye to zombie cells and
unlock your fountain of youth with
qualia senolytic that's neurohacker
decom inside for an extra 15% off your
purchase these statements have not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration products and statements
are not intended to diagnose treat cure
or prevent any
disease hey did you ever experience like
now do you did you ever deal with you
haven't seen those videos I'm like so
nervous by this conversation I'm like
I'm an open book I'm so vulnerable I'm
like no I know this is great this is
good I said yeah good I I hope you're
you know you'll enjoy this and when I
come on yours you could ask me anything
I I like honestly I'm I know more people
listen to yours than mine though that's
good so I'm like oh no well now they're
not now they're going to listen to yours
and they should um if you're talking
about real stuff that's what people want
to hear um the second I started talking
about real feelings and not being you
know trying to be funny and trying to I
just you know sort of I'm just the I I I
never have pictured myself like a like a
celebrity or like you know I never
always felt like I never belonged so you
know when I'm talking to people there is
that excitement there is that but how do
you do that how do you navigate through
that how do you deal like I was going to
ask you how do you deal with uh I mean
have you dealt with anxiety or
depression and what did you do to get
over that or what do you do to to um
work on
that um I I wouldn't say that I've ever
been clinically depressed and and I
think that it's easy
you know I I'm glad that everyone talks
more about the feelings of anxiety and
depression and then but also recognizing
that there is very clinical versions of
those um experiences as well uh and so
you know I I've I've been in therapy
since I was 18 I've been in and out of
therapy what got you in therapy love
therapy what got you in I I had a friend
she was like one of my best friends in
La when I was a teenager she was like
the first friend that I really made
there
and she was in therapy and she was
struggling with um she was struggling
with some mental health and and so uh I
realized that I was feeling overwhelmed
and I was like well she's into it so
maybe I'll try it and then I got in
there and I was like oh this is awesome
this is great it it just started
connecting all these dots of um it made
sense of things that I couldn't
understand and took the weight off of um
me just that it would like it's me hi
I'm the problem it's me which I think is
also important to uh acknowledge when it
is you um but then also it help helped
me give Grace in situations to try to
and and hold people accountable I think
that's another thing it helped me do um
is that it help made me hold myself
accountable but it also gave me
permission to hold other people
accountable and as kind of like a type a
perfectionist people pleaser it can be
that can be hard for me to do don't you
want like a therapist like my therapy
session last week goes do this do it was
the first time I've ever heard like most
therapists go well what do you think
about that well what do you want to do
about that and the answer is right there
in front of you I should stop doing that
I should uh I shouldn't snack at
night as much as I do that's why I feel
like you know crappier in the morning I
mean that's a bad example but um what do
you snack on at night I think that's
well I just bought a movie theater thing
like popcorn maker I Love Popcorn like
nobody and I make the best popcorn there
is like it's that's dangerous and I uh I
love it I love it but I always feel the
next day I'm just dragging for a couple
hours cuz it's just like I guess all the
salt and all the the salt but I got to
stop it so I'm trying to slow down there
but what I'm saying is like those those
things that you don't like a lot of
people think I don't need therapy I just
I'm fine my life's fine but you could
also make your life better and you could
understand certain things that you do
you do for a reason and if you don't
like the things that you do you can
change them and when you're talking
about you know things that you look back
in the past and you shame yourself and
you're like oh I did this I'm a bad
person I'm I regret that I it's all
these things and when you start talking
about them you realize like we don't
we're not born into this world and we
just are all perfect we're we're all
flawed and that's just a reality and you
are going to do things that
you know you look back and you go oh my
God if anybody knew that they would
think I'm just not a nice person or if
I'm not but you know you're it's all
about the
uh it's all about the end game right
like if you evolve that's the goal is to
evolve to not be that's the win that's
the win so you know if you know I was a
certain way when I was younger it's it's
not who I become today and who I'm
becoming it's um so therapy has taught
me a lot about how to you know love
myself how to light myself to you know
to look in the mirror and go hey dude
you're a good guy you're a good guy you
do good things sometimes you're a dick
right you didn't need to say that you
didn't need to say the dick part you
just say you love yourself and you know
do you do you do are you good to
yourself do you love
yourself I know I know You' probably
talked about it already but just so I
have context when did you start going to
Y how old were you right after you
didn't go out with me again I thank God
no no everybody's like oh shut up Rosen
bom enough with that no
honestly I think I went through this
breakup where it was my fault and I
tried to get her
back and it didn't
happen and I just it was devastating and
I know that I caused it it was my
fault and so I when one of my friends
suggested is like you should talk to
someone I'm like well what are they
going to I what am I going to do I went
through a break poor me but no but
people go through this this is what you
have to you need it's nice to talk to
someone objectively and just say hey I
feel this emptiness I don't want to do
anything I lost my appetite I I can't
stop I'm obsessive thinking about this
and you know and I I was never I've
never been the guy where I was like ever
checking up on someone or show like not
weird [__] it was just in my head I just
felt like [__] you carried it yeah I
carried it and it took a while to get
rid of that and just talking to someone
for an hour and I a lot of times Ryan
here I got him into therapy but you know
we start we think I don't want to go
[__] I don't want to talk I'm not in the
mood I'm GNA cancel this I'll eat the
hundred bucks or whatever the [__] it is
and I'll just I'm not going to do it
today I don't I have nothing to talk
about and then all of a sudden you you
start talking and uh all of a sudden
you're like holy [__] I got five minutes
left I I still want to get into this I
want every time you're you just letting
things out kind of clears a little bit
of that you know a little bit of your
mind so you know so and I'm a natural
talker I can go I can I I had to also
realize that I
can like there's certain like I was I
would lean on friendships a lot and so
that's where I also had to you know
check myself in adulthood is really
making sure I had a place where I could
go that also wasn't like oh let me
release all this weight that I'm
carrying and be like here you organize
it you know you Marie condo it for me um
you know where I had to kind of take
responsibility and do that so it didn't
affect other friendships and
relationships of mine um but the other
thing I'll say that I always like to say
for anyone that listens and is like well
I'm never going to go to or I tried
therapy once and it didn't work out for
me is like it's not what that's not one
size fits all either you know it it is
you if you go to a therapist and you
don't like the way they do therapy like
you should always make a few
appointments like you know a a lot of
therapists will offer like potentially a
free introduction you know session or
change therapist if you don't feel the
vibe just change it change therapist
it's not your fault if it doesn't work
out it's no and if they're a good
therapist they should say like
absolutely like let me know if you need
any recommendations hope you find
someone anyone who to guilt you into
staying like is usually not a good not a
good no I had one guy I left him years
ago I went to him probably a handful of
times and because one of my friends went
to him he's like he's really good and
it's like the third session the guy's
like eating a Subway sandwich while he's
talking to me in the room he's just
eating a Subway sandwich I'm sorry I
haven't had lunch are you okay with that
I'm like no do I have a choice have a
choice you're hungry what am I going to
say no and then it's awkward for the
next hour but you're just you're picking
out on this [__] sandwich do you have
to put so much Mayo on there it's on
your [__]
lips so yeah um no one looks
professional eating a sub boy sandwich
it is no no no uh were
you Blown Away by the success of ampire
Diaries were you like cuz that was like
the first big boom
right and I mean were your parents blown
away and I wanted to talk about your
parents and see if they they wanted you
to get in acting be like oh you don't
you I don't know if you should do this
but knew you were talented you were
always singing you're always doing these
things but did you were you surprised by
the the enormity of it um I
remember I knew that I was a part of
something
special I had never done a pilot episode
of anything I had tested for
pilots and so I was very
green and um and I just remember at many
group dinners after hours and
and everyone who I had admired in the
industry for a really long time who I am
lucky enough to consider friends now I
just remember
them like they had this like look of
like Christmas morning on their face
like there's something special happening
and so I didn't I didn't know what it
was but I wasn't scared I just knew that
like this was going to be fun and you
did 171 episodes you
you did more episodes than I I did eight
well I didn't do the full ones but but
just the success of the the you know of
the series itself um you know it it's
really incredible and I know you you
feel that when you you do conventions as
well and and you know it's interesting I
feel like there was like what comiccons
and conventions used to be back in the
day are very different than what they
are right now um one I think just
because more people participate in them
on both sides um from all it's not just
like a niche kind of genre thing um and
also like I think that this generation
of consumers of like entertainment
consumers like they want a piece of like
what they're seeing and they want to
like you know to have the opportunity
like having the all access on like
social media and seeing you know there
is no like secret version of like you I
just read like Evelyn Hugo the seven
husbands of Evelyn Hugo and it's a
wonderful book that's on your Instagram
I just posted it today yeah I noticed it
today and I was likeing at it's so good
I finished it last night um I like it
but it's really good um but it's all old
Hollywood and so and there is no my
there's no like secret life there's you
know people make sure that they have a
connection with the viewers so but all
that to say
um it's really it is wild it it is wild
I I wouldn't say I was surprised
um but I was surprised that I was a part
of
it do when you go to conventions do you
ever have fans that
are emotional or talk to you about like
how it changed their life or it meant so
much to them because I have that which
is pretty freaking um profound to have
someone say you know your show saved me
I'm like come on I mean I know the the
song on the show was somebody saved me
but like how did how did a a show like
this save you you know in my mind I
don't say it like come on what's wrong
with you but like when they start
telling me like this is what my dad and
I watched and my dad passed but I always
had these memories and when I went
through a hard time I'd go back and I'd
watch these and whatever it was and it
just like blew me away how something
that seems so trivial um you know we get
paid to make pretend and and then people
coming up to you and saying these things
it really had an impact on me and it
still has an impact but I'm sure you
you've gotten
that 100% um and it is a lot of uh
parents and children or some people
who've lost um significant people in
their life and that would enjoy a show
together um
and and and and also you know being a
part of a of something that was rooted
in grief you know that you know while
some I think could argue Ro that it was
rooted in love A lot of it was rooted in
grief and loss so I get that a lot um
and and also I totally get it you know
like I um I gosh what I I told this I
was at the airport this like two years
ago and I I was and there was someone
walking by she was a a flight attendant
and she came back with someone else like
one of her
co-workers and she just started crying
about like this loss that she had
experienced in her life and she had
gotten so depressed and a relationship
that had ended and and she just started
to cry and said you know she was so
alone and she but she could watch you
know a show every single night and know
that like she could come home to that
and then I start crying because I said
and she's like I know you probably think
I sound crazy I'm like no you're not
crazy at all um I have the same thing
like I have those same feelings and I
have shows that I'm come home to and
that I know if I need to cry or if I
need to laugh or I like bouts of
insomnia that I can just like leave my
computer on and it plays in the
background and and so um and I've also
learned that like I feel really grateful
to have learned like that it's such a
waste of time to be cool like all the
cool people in the world are really like
the fans you know what I mean like
people who are willing to be fanatic
about something that they love that's
and without any shame or like guilt or
like they're like like this is
embarrassing no it's not like it
shouldn't be embarrassing to like
celebrate something that brings you Joy
that should not be embar like and I'm
talking about very simple things you
know what like but things that are like
a a show or a movie or a universe of or
a book whatever or a book or an a
musical artist you know like that's okay
and it makes you feel like you're doing
your job I mean you know a lot of times
we do I mean look I I've done a lot of
[__] man I mean just when I and I call
it [__] like not not good you know
product out there and I've done some
great stuff and some but that's it's
called a job you're working it's a job
sometimes you do something that yeah
sometimes you do something that impacts
people and I think it's great were you
you did you get along with everybody on
the set was it always just one big happy
family or were there's a couple people
you were kind of like I do not want to
work with this
guy it was like
um I what's funny is I was just uh I was
at the lake with uh with Julie pleck and
um and in Atlanta and and also Karina
McKenzie and their incredible writers
Julie is writer showrunner and Karina as
well has gone on to also she was a
writer on um I always forget like what
the because we're still on strike so I'm
trying to be respectful of not like
mentioning exact things can't talk about
people who I've worked with and so um
but we were just talking about like how
and then and then someone else who was a
who was one of our ad's um assistant
directors for many many years uh was
there as well and one of our camera
operators we were just having like a
little like catchup and it was just so
we were just laughing at how often
it would be like midnight on you know on
a Friday and we'd all be like all right
well where are we going like we all like
want to keep hanging out together see
that's we always hung out together we're
still hanging out together even the guys
and girls are just the girls no no these
are these like guys and girls like I I
especially the conventions are really
helpful as far as um as far as like on
other actors like I mean me and like a
whole group of the guys just like we're
literally we'd be like all right I'll
see you in a couple weeks in you know
this city and Berlin or what wherever we
were last year in Liverpool and we like
I plan all the dinners because you know
someone's got to be the planner and the
mom of the group and I'm too much of a
type A personality to just go to any
restaurant that isn't that great so i'
would rather make the reservations like
months ahead of time you know it's funny
because the last thing I wanted to do on
Smallville was hang out with anybody in
the cast or or crew all we did no like
it wasn't so funny I know I've heard
this from other no no no it wasn't like
we didn't like each other but when
you're working 12 15 hours a day a lot
of us were uh mostly Tom Tom was very
honest I don't want to see you I have
two days off I don't want to see you I'm
like I totally get it Seinfeld again but
you know that's but I but like now it
seems like after years have passed we
had a real respect for each other and
now when we go to cons at time and I
have become really close friends we have
the other podcast tovil and Kristen and
I who was Lana she she and I are really
cool and we love seeing each other we
love spending time together now it's
like it we now that we've grown up a
little bit well they have but you know
so but it's nice because you you hear a
lot of horror stories so and there's a
lot of Youth going on in your show so I
figured there was a lot of like cool and
angst and this and that and look we it's
with any I mean High School's four years
this was
eight like you know like eight years I
wasn't popular though in high school I
wasn't either you weren't I left High
School you what do you mean you left
High School I left halfway through my
junior year and graduated through
correspondence really yeah why why did
you do that did you do it because you
because you're acting in your music to
become an international pop
star how did your parents feel about how
did your did your parents feel about
that
um uh they were great they were
incredibly supportive actually my dad's
a cardiovascular surgeon and my mom um
uh worked for a very long time as an
environmental engineer um and so for
them to both succeed in their fields
they uh they to them that was like their
version of becoming international pop
stars so they also they always supported
me as I I mean I did vot vocal lessons I
started a girl group I like got a band
together I'd like you know I I was
always instigating everything and then
um I had gotten a development deal in La
which was a thing that they used to do
we basically kind of like sponsor an
artist and and you know pay for their
sessions with other writers and
producers or I don't even know if they
were paying at that point if all these
people who were writing with me or were
just showing up because you just hope
something comes from it but they
basically um and then I was able to make
a demo and it was shopped and this was
uh so I left halfway through my junior
year to with a development deal and then
within six months I had a record deal
and a publishing deal so my parents let
me stay J that's just
insane it's so silly like that's insane
do you love music more than acting do
you would you rather be a like if
somebody said would you rather be a rock
star or an actor I'd say rockar I'd
rather be a rock star if I had you know
and I have a band and we play and we do
we don't try to be rock stars we're just
write all the music and uh Rob and I
just work well together and we love to
play Virtual live and we played some out
and we have two albums and we just enjoy
it and love it and there's a passion and
do you still have that passion for music
I know now you're a mom you're a mom and
you've got all this stuff going on do
you still like because you you've had
albums you've had success I mean a lot
of success but do you want to continue
do you want to continue music do you
want to still kind of keep writing and
playing no I haven't written in a very
long time why um BEC I I I have a very
complicated relationship with like music
when it involves me I love music I am
staring at my record player in my
handful of records that are like that
I've kept away from my moving boxes and
I'm so excited to get that back going I
bought a piano just so I could hear the
sound of my children like slamming their
fingers into it I just love that noise
God you like that noise I love it oh I
love it because they're just there
because I always I spent so long like
one of the things I kept saying in this
last year which could bring me down a
whole other tangent so I will attempt
not to do that but that I I like last
year um my entire personality became
Golf and it kind of became like a joke
for a while um wow I love golf you're
playing golf well I was playing golf
it's it's a bigger Longer story um but
accidentally became like a golfer and um
and but I was not but I'm not good at it
and but because get a golf I I mean but
I'm not great at it and so I was trying
to be but what I wanted to do was be
better at being like being good at not
being great at something like that is
what I've really wanted to be better at
and I and I remember being like I want
my kids to be able to just play messy
keys on a piano and not have to be like
no this sounds good and this sounds bad
because when you're creating art like I
I would just be paralyzed by like a
white piece of paper and if I started
something that I had decided like wasn't
the way it was supposed to turn out I'd
be like well then what's the point and I
just like I want to create an an
environment in which like you know there
is no like one sound of and they'll find
it like I wish I'd had that to just be
able to like play a bunch of keys and
and wonder like how does this sound what
is this and be curious as opposed to um
so constricted I love what you just said
and what I interpret that
as is for
me it's
always I'm playing softball tonight I've
got to be great I've got to hit a home
run I've got to be the star I'm gonna
play anything we played cornhole the
other night I gotta freaking show
everybody I'm a cornhole Master uh I'm
going to write a great script I'm you're
putting so much pressure on yourself and
you're not enjoying things that you're
like I have to be perfect and the
reality is you can't be so if you could
just enjoy things that you're not really
great at but you enjoy doing them and
watching your kids just mess up and
learn that it's okay to just be stupid
and playful and happy and I think that's
because we put so much pressure on
ourselves and the world we feel like the
world puts pressure that we have to like
if we put something out there oh it has
to sound great it has to be because we
have to compete we have to show that
we're just as good and what I gather is
that you're saying in a lot of ways you
want to just be able to not put as much
pressure on yourself and just enjoy
things yes and and not to say that there
aren't things that I want to win at and
that I that I consider myself to be good
at and have a level of expectation of
how I should operate within that field
or experience but but also in things
that like I'm not a professional golfer
I'm picking it up I mean it like I it
all comes back to I keep getting just so
many jokes about how like so often in
this last year I'm like I went to
Scotland last October and had this like
life-changing trip but but I did and I
found myself playing like I wasn't
playing the old course but I was in St
Andrews and I had hadn't golfed in years
and I was alone and and just showed up I
I you know hired a caddy and she was
like all right you ready and then I I
didn't even have time to warm up and I'm
on Jubilee and it's one of the windiest
days of the year and I was like I don't
know if I can do this I don't know what
I'm doing and he was just like oh just
hit the damn ball and I was like okay
and sometimes you just got to hit the
damn ball yeah might not go straight I
might go over but just hit the hit the
damn ball or just take him and I had a
great time his name is Dr Tom he also
happens to do Sports Dr Tom accent did
he have a really th SK he was just like
he was the best sometimes you just got
to hit the ball and honestly I had the
best freaking day of my life it was just
so fun and it was so beautiful and if I
had decided that this wasn't something
that like I was good at or some a place
that I wasn't shouldn't be at you know
or that it's only for like really it's
like and you know it was just so silly
to even have thought that I was just it
was wonderful so sometimes you just got
to get out there and hit the damn ball
you heard her hit the damn ball folks or
just take a swing even if you don't hit
it you swung yeah pick up the club just
pick up the club yeah that's a metaphor
or it's a yeah it's not it's uh what was
I going to say to you um do you still
love acting do you still want to
act yeah I really do I really really do
I'd had a period where I wasn't working
very much um and just home with the
family more I'd also had a second child
during Co and um and I went back to it
and um I had two different jobs one was
like getting back to it and just you
know four months after I had a baby and
and um you know just to kind of work a
little bit and and it was and it felt
nice I I liked like having that
um that part of my identity you know
kind of
Awakened um and then to go back to work
and then I worked again a little bit
more last year and and and it was just
nice to you know have things that I was
nervous of whether I was going to be
good at it but like know that I could be
good at it and and do the best that I
could and and I I like I really do love
it though I love being on a set I love I
love uh a scene partner I love um you
know making sense of some like
understanding a character and
understanding like what makes someone
else across from me in the scene like
what their triggers are what their
buttons are and trying to push them and
and see if I can get to to them and and
I just also love storytelling like I
love TV I love TV TV is my favorite
person in the world I have so many shows
that I watch I also do watch a lot of
reality TV so I like that is also I know
with but that's I I think it's very
interesting like current character
development from These reality TV stars
is very interesting to watch you know
what funny I I uh I sold a reality
series because I'm a big fan of horror
movies like I love scary
stuff and so my friend John heer who's
who's Napoleon Dynamite um we sold the
show where we're we're just two guys
going to the scariest places on Earth
two like idiots so where we go to like
the catacombs of Paris and Transylvania
castles and like stuff and just like
it's just our personalities and we love
horror and we love scary so really think
of something so it's something like I
never would do that but I'm like wait a
minute you love scary stuff you love
yeah you're G to hang out with your
friend why can't you just go do that why
so I mean it's not like I'm doing mil
island did you see
that I did not watch that one oh my God
so all these mils I know I know I have a
problem with that like the name itself
no that was also a joke name on a
different show it was a 30 Rock joke it
was a 30 Rock joke I'm not look my
friend Nate I was in Indiana and uh I
picked him up to go to dinner and I go
hey man did you got some sleep last
night or something and he goes no
I go okay he's not a man in many words
and I go what' you do he goes well I
watched a show called mil Island and I
go mil Island he's like yeah all the
women are mils and then all of a sudden
they bring in all these 21y old guys who
were their kids so now all the mils and
the yeah or the kids are no I I mean it
was I had to watch I had to it was just
so I couldn't believe what we and you
know what's funny it was on the [__]
Learning Channel
Candace how is that how are you learning
I mean I think we should all learn that
we don't need that show maybe that's I
think that's it or maybe they're just
studying to see who watches that show
and what they can learn from that
data I don't know uh all right look this
is called This is called [__] talking
[__] talking with Candace King I'm going
to ask you questions from my top tier
patrons so go to patreon.com inside of
you and get to ask questions and a bunch
of other cool [__] all right Leanne says
do you believe in the Supernatural and
have you had any experiences along those
lines I I believe that there's I don't
know if like like they're I don't want
to piss off the ghosts of my house but
um yeah I definitely believe that
there's something you know I definitely
feel I've lived in a lot of old places
and I've had a lot of people say that
the places I've lived and feel like
their's um they might say ghost or
Spirits or VI Vibes um I keep I have
this running joke right now that the
ghost of my house that I just moved into
it's almost 100 years old who and that
they they like my kids they're very nice
to my kids so there's nothing like scary
going on there but they're just like
really [__] with me and like just
trying to like show me who's boss
really I don't know know like some
Cabinetry almost fell on my head in the
kitchen that I'm trying to renovate like
every time I turn around like I had like
a like bees in a tree like there was a
smell but I but I also just got all the
air vents cleaned out and so that took
away that but there's always like little
things and I don't know I never pay
attention enough to like see if there
like like did I leave that cabinet and
drawer open or was that just there I
don't know but it at this point you're
thinking about it but sure I I feel like
it is a running joke now that I've never
lived anywhere that didn't have like
spirits of the history of the house but
I think I'm winning them over yeah I
think that they like my renovation ideas
and they know that like I'm laughing
with them and I also like I think that
they honestly part of it was I was
playing a lot of Taylor Swift and now
that I'm like post eras tour they've had
it and it's I've like slowed it down my
t- Swift in the house and I feel like
they've calmed down a little bit I think
that they were just like you got to
switch it up got to switch it up Raj
tell me about a recent time you someone
helped you out
oh my through the divorce right you were
talking about that well yeah but like
also just uh you
know um just yeah even just like moving
into this house I mean it's I haven't
like the amount of people who have just
um supported me like my friend who also
was my realtor like she's helped in it's
just been this wonderful um sense of
community uh that I found here in
Nashville and I've been so grateful
and so um to feel just like you know
people checking in and people just um
being like hey how's the move going can
like when you move no matter what you
have like so many people help out and
also you know I you know co-parent um
but also when my kids are with me
they're with me and so to have friends
that are willing to come by and and you
know like one of my friends she was
visiting in town we've known each other
since we were 16 and I was like you know
it's a school night I can't go out and
but I can make you dinner here and so
she comes here and is playing with my
kids and we're catching up and she's
having dinner while like you know one's
doing gymnastics and another one's like
throwing dinner on the floor on the
floor and and she's just it's like that
kind of love and support is really
beautiful at this point in life I had uh
I grew up in uh Newberg Indiana which is
about two hours from Nashville and I
played hockey in Nashville I love
Nashville I mean Nashville's pretty
banging City yeah think I like Nashville
I've thought about that's one of those
places that I've considered like if I
moved I'd go to Nashville would I like
it I don't know I don't know what you
like oh good Michelle L who inspires
you who inspires me what's the first
thing that came to your mind just now
when I said that um my kids and Lucille
Ball you love Lucille Ball my mom loves
Lucille Ball I love Lucille Ball I was
just like I love Lucio ball and also
just reading rereading that book um like
that or just reading the Evelyn Hugo
book I was thinking a lot of just uh you
know her career and just how much
she like the fact that Lucio ball like
created her whole like she created how
we watch television the three camera
structure I mean her and Desi arz but
like but the fact that them together and
that even after they like they divorced
and they separated like he still came
back to do all of the show like Vivian
Vance worked with her on her later show
like it's just really incredible what
they did and she also succeeded later in
life I mean she was in her like mid to
late 30s I think when I Love Lucy
started um wow it's it's just incredible
um I'm just so in awe of Lucy and Lucy
and Desi um deso Productions and it's
that the whole story um but also I just
I love watching I Love Lucy and like the
mink episode cracks me up too cuz she's
kind of like she's actually not the
funny one like everyone like she's kind
of more the like everyone else is
messing with her and where she's usually
the one messing with everyone else but
Jessica B when was the last time you
surprised yourself last time I surprised
myself I think I saw something behind
you too I think I saw something like I
don't know if my eyes were playing
tricks on me but when you were saying
all that Supernatural stuff I thought I
saw something but maybe it's nothing it
was outside maybe oh it's a flag I
there's like a flag oh kind of creeped
me out I was like oh my god did I just
see that after she well we captured
something here oh my God this is
amazing um the last time I surprised
myself uh was I think in parent in
mothering I surprise myself a lot like I
find myself in situations where I'm just
like oh gosh this is this is a moment
and not like and I just need to take a
deep breath and like walk through this
you know talk through this moment very
slowly and um but I surprise myself as a
as a mother a lot I don't know that's
what popped into my I like that that's
sweet um Eternal
Flame and and also voes Cary voes Cary
is one of my favorite
songs you know that song uh not you
Candace uh Ryan do you know that Eternal
Flame h no do you know uh voices carry
Hush Hush Tuesday keep it down now
voices
[Music]
car no shut up I love when she says shut
up you know what I'm talking about
Candace yes so voices carrye I recorded
when I was
17 um and it was actually it was not my
doing I was not that cool it was my
producer Stacy Jones who had mentioned
it um Stacy's awesome Stacy's who got me
the no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no what are you doing on your
phone I I wasn't I wasn't doing anything
I wasn't going to look up your song I
was just playing the original cuz oh
playing the original okay yeah cuz you
you don't want to hear that
[Music]
look anyway that's a you know what I
still don't know it's a great it's a
great song I did not I wish I was that
cool when I was 17 years old um but
that's my only attachment to it is like
the that recording it then um and then
Eternal
Flame I performed on the
show and uh were n also not my were you
nervous in front of the crew and cast
yes and also that was not I just
remember getting a text one night so I
was like was out at dinner and I
remember I think it was like juliean and
Kevin text me and we're just like hey
remember how you said you were a singer
like are you good or like can you can
you sing for real or was that just
like like on I don't they were just like
can can you sing and I was like yeah I
think I can um and then they put it in
the show and and I just was like oh gosh
and I remember even just like going but
what's what is fun is I did get to
go I ended up back at the
studio where um I recorded my record
when I was 17 so it was like very kismi
that like one of their kind of producing
Partners who also like co- rented the
studio with them who I had known back
when I was a teenager too like he was
the one doing the session and so I
literally um and went back to that
studio where I used to record when I was
17 years old and and recorded that part
which was very fun um but I also like
never thought I would do it again they
were like well it's it's weird to have
like supernatural beings and then one of
them just randomly sings so we probably
won't do that again I was likeo okay
good and then a couple years later it
was like every other episode I was like
what are we doing here guys this is my
nightmare I do not enjoy this I don't
like
this like are we please stop um and
eventually it ended hey you know I I
think you have a great voice I think you
should I think you should keep singing
in fact we're working on our next album
and if I have something in there would
you would you record something even if
it's like a backup or something I will
support you finding a wonderful artist
out there you don't want to sing you
wouldn't want to sing on it at all just
a little he I'm just not there yet and I
don't know when I'll be there my kids
hear me sing all the time what if you
listen to a song and you're like you
know I really like that song and I could
do this this is easy if you just want
this like you know then you can let's
not say no just
yet let's keep it up in the air perfect
what's your favorite James Taylor
song I mean Sweet Baby James just came
into my mind but I know that's probably
not my faite all time well this has been
awesome I'm glad I'm doing yours too I
know super
bloom super bloom a super bloom podcast
wherever you listen to podcast it's been
fun I honestly I do love it so much
because it gives me a reason to reach
out to people that I'm like a super fan
of that I would never normally talk to
and you know um I like even sitting down
uh like with I got to like hang out with
Emily Henry who I love her as an author
and you know which I would never
normally do and then also I there like
there's this really cool woman who she's
a glaciologist and so to be able to talk
with her about how she's like traveling
the world and just chasing history as it
melts away to have a better
understanding of you know where where we
all came from before it's gone forever
it's like I love talking about that kind
of stuff it's my favorite thing so
there's all kinds of conversations
um but it you know uh and that's that's
really my excuse listening if you listen
to Super Bloom you're getting just like
a snapshot of my mind in all in in my
browser history of all the little like
spirals I go down I'm nervous what are
you gonna ask
me oo so much now I'm ready I'm glad you
got to go first this was all part of the
plan oh great yeah I have a feeling
where this is going to go I just my mind
takes takes me somewhere well I love
talking to you I feel like I could talk
to you forever you're just awesome
you're just so easy to talk to I I love
like you're such a I could tell what an
amazing mom you are an amazing friend
and you're super talented and I'm just
happy and proud of you and um you're
going to stay in Nashville you just
bought this 100-year-old haunted house
so you're probably not going to move
into Los Angeles anytime soon nope I'm
here I gotta I got to hang out with my
ghosts I can't leave them you know they
need my company do they have
names no no let's name them let's name
them I I know well no I I don't want to
anger them I'm not trying to they need
to tell me their names but I know that I
feel like there's two uh this has been
awesome uh I'll see you in a week or so
right don't do too much deep thinking on
this one I'm GNA start I'm gonna start
typing on my computer right now guys you
got to go listen to it super bloom
Candace King uh thanks for being here uh
I appreciate you thanks thank
you beautiful inside and out so pleasant
and I was like man I would have totally
married her you know she's that kind of
presence where I just felt like she's
got a good Soul she's smart she's
beautiful she was just you know and she
was very open and like forthcoming and
uh I always dig that so Candace you're
uh you're top-notch with me thank you
for being on the podcast I really do
appreciate it um now we've had two
vampire diary um cast members now we
just need the um summer holder yeah the
summer hold Institute because we've been
talking about him a lot on the other
podcast I wonder if he'd do it he might
be big time too big time I'm gonna start
I'm gonna start tweeting him go you're
too big time I bet he'd come you do yeah
I don't
know I think we have the same lawyer so
I'm G to talk to my lawyer there you go
all right uh thanks for listening uh if
you didn't listen to the beginning go
listen to that cuz it's got a lot of
stuff I have a bio uh on my Instagram uh
you go to the bio has a link tree it
says all the cons we're doing it says
we're going to you know all Rhode Island
and Cameo and the merch store check it
out all right let's read the top tier
patrons here they are top tiers
patreon.com inside of you couldn't do
this without you I love you and uh Ryan
you don't have them do you you can't
read with me I mean I could pull them up
on my phone but we can also play The
Guessing Game again Leah
and Leah and oh it's not Craig Craig no
remember it was it used to be Leah s and
Kristen K right so now it's Leah and
Kristen oh they're best friends and
they're one well that's neat that's neat
which means one of them canceled their
subscription that's okay and they joined
together times are hard no I think it's
a cool thing I think it's awesome little
Lisa U Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert
d w w b correct Robert B I'll give you
three chances to hit it while I'm
staring at you if you're wrong God Jason
W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D Jennifer N
Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Mike e l Don
supro 99 more Santiago M Chad
D B Chad r l y w w correct said that
Leanne P Maddie s Belinda n Dave H Dave
Hall I love my Dave Hall he's very you
know very subtle subtle he's got a cat
Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom n
Talia M Betsy d ranan c Corey l m Corey
n what goes with Cory Corey K correct
Dev Nexon Michelle D nothing think
Canadian a yep correct Jeremy C
Brandy C what comes after Jeremy C
Brandy D correct Joanie R comes before
Bry Jeremy c b Joanie B then there's
Joey oh no it's getting rough L just
think
Joey Joy see Joey McIntyre from Back
Street Boys or is that in sync or is
that 85 degrees or what are you talking
about here no wait isn't the McIntyre is
that a new kid on the Block new kid on
the Block Joy M yeah Eugene n Leah
correct Corey
Angela F [__]
Mel
c s
Christine
C this is getting bad s Eric h Shane R
Andrew M Amanda R Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie k jel jammon j Leanne p no
and and no jam and J and lean J there's
a lean P but it's jam and J Lee and J
okay Luna R Mike F met all these guys
Stone H just hung out with him Kayla
stay wild moonchild Brian L Kendall L
Cara C Jessica B Kyle F hey buddy how
you doing Marisol Kaye J Brian a Ashley
F Maran Louise L Romeo B Frank B Jen T
Nikki L April R Derek n JD Ward rlp
Ginger Insomniac Rachel D Laura Li l
Melissa H Nicholas W Stephanie and Evan
and that's
it and those are the top tier patrons we
love you very much and uh you mean a lot
to me and if uh you know thank you and
that's about it for today's podcast so
uh from Michael rosom here in the
Hollywood Hills of
California I'm Ryan ha I'm here
too are you am I peace sign in the wave
to the camera we love you and uh be good
to
[Music]
yourself